hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Terminator Genisys review Khaleesi
Sarah Connor taking over for Cersei
Sarah Connor in case you guys didn't
remember this is actually the fifth
Terminator movie but the sixth
Terminator installment because of the TV
series with Lena Headey that was a Fox
show from a long time ago but if you dig
really deep you can actually find the
episodes you can definitely chart
different eras in the franchise you have
like the James Cameron era with those
first two films then you then you have
like the middle films that we can forget
about number three and four then you
have the TV era with Cersei Lannister
and Summer Glau and now we have Daenerys
Targaryen Sarah Connor the real question
is is how do you tell a new and
interesting story in the terminator
universe when the premise is always the
same machines trying to defeat man by
changing the timeline typically the way
the previous Terminator films have
addressed this is that you go back to
different points in time or you have
films that focus on different characters
inside the paradigm I'd say this film
has the most in common with the first
Terminator film it honors a lot of very
specific moments from that very first
film so if you want to prepare for this
like if you're not gonna see it till
this weekend I would rewatch the
original Terminator film it felt like
there was just enough eye winking
without being too nostalgic but the film
just like never quite finds it's
emotional core I just to hand it to him
the the writers definitely tried to
leave behind some of the pre assumptions
that you have going into this you know
in that John Connor plays a certain role
Kyle Reese and Sarah Connor have have
their own roles then you have the bad
terminators you have the sympathetic
terminator usually each of the film's
themselves try to kind of shuffle the
cast and in the way that they focus on
on that core group this film definitely
has a little fun with that but I feel
like it just never connects with you on
the visceral level of a movie say like
Mad Max fury road it's not a totally
fair comparison because I feel like
inside this Terminator universe there
are a lot more story constraints than
there are would say like Mad Max that
film wasn't quite as burdened as The
Terminator films are with certain
predetermined story points as in you
know machines take over humans try to go
back in time to change the past so that
they can defeat the machines
it makes me think a lot about what's
going to be going on with with a flash
season 2 now that they've introduced
time-travel on that show
because it's like how do you explain the
logic of time travel without getting too
silly so the film addresses that in a
really funny way and everybody's
wondering about emilia clarke because
she's sister needs a break into like
some really big mainstream movies now
she doesn't quite hold a candle to linda
hamilton but but again they're they're
really trying to do something different
with these characters so i try not to
make too many direct comparisons with
with other portrayals of that character
like lena headey Sarah Connor very
different from Amelia Clarke's Sarah
Connor the changes in her character are
totally explained by the logic of the
film so it's not a really big issue I
don't want to say too much about Matt
Smith's role because he was a lot of fun
he was one of my top three characters in
the film but to explain his role any
more than that it is a bit spoilery
Jason Clarke play my second favorite
performance in the film you know behind
Emilia Clarke as Sarah Connor this is
really her film as much as the first
Terminator film is Linda Hamilton's film
there was a certain point in the the
James Cameron era where the film shifted
and like Terminator 2 became all about
John Connor whereas the first film was
all about Sarah Connor the problem with
the story I think is is that it doesn't
follow her story in a meaningful way
it's almost like halfway through the
film the story shifts perspectives and
in the whole film tries to build around
a different character whereas you know
you're kind of expecting it to be about
Emilia Clarke I understand they're
trying to do something new but but I
feel like it really kind of takes you
out of the story and even you kind of
lose your emotional connection with
Sarah Connor sometimes when they cast
certain actors in a film like they get a
really big actor they'll they'll change
the story to feature them more and
sometimes that works sometimes it
doesn't
I feel in this case it does not and I'm
not talking about the Governator Arnold
Schwarzenegger just talk about his
performance he will always and forever
be the Terminator along you know with
Robert Patrick of the t1000 we have to
give him credit to a new most every
major store in detail about the movie
going into it so there weren't a whole
lot of surprises and in terms of plot
twists but there is one really nice
moment you need to keep your eyes peeled
for it that that kind of honors the
legacy of Arnold Schwarzenegger and
Robert Patrick I have no idea what their
plans for the future of the series are
the rights have been passed around a lot
of different places that's one of the
reasons why it took so long to get this
film off the ground the film does a good
job of closing this story so that it can
exist by itself and it's not
a big middle finger ending where where
there's a cliffhanger that's completely
unexplained so you won't walk away
feeling like you got cheated out of an
ending but definitely expect more
Terminator films whether they come in
two years or four years or five years
they'll come there will be more
terminator so here's my big question for
you guys when you get a chance to see
terminator let me know what's your
favorite part of the film and what do
you want to see them do with the
franchise in the next installment I mean
like what can you do that's new with
terminator that we haven't seen before I
would hope that they would have the guts
to focus on different characters and
just go with that just just leave
pre-existing characters behind like
maybe you take one or two but you don't
stick to the old paradigm that's why I
get really excited when I when I hear
about movies like Star Trek 3 they they
just announced that it's called Star
Trek beyond they're like it is
definitely not going to be the search
for Spock which was the original third
movie with this same cast but I
definitely give a giant thumbs up to me
the Clarkes performance I mean she's my
favorite part of the film I feel like
any shortcomings of the film or the
fault of the script Alan Taylor's the
director he directed a lot of Game of
Thrones Lee's worked with emilia clarke
before he also directed Thor the dark
world he's done some some big stuff he's
a fairly competent director so I feel
like most of the issues with this movie
are with the story itself with the
script but it's still definitely worth
checking out so go check it out and then
come back on this video and let me know
what you think just do be careful to use
spoiler tags if you if you have seen it
just because most people probably won't
see this till the weekend so there's a
whole bunch of stuff happening this week
I'm slowly getting ready for Comic Con
so I'm gonna start rolling those videos
out in between flash and Marvel stuff so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
it's gonna be a lot of fun while you
guys wait for all that stuff to post you
can click here for my latest Game of
Thrones video from yesterday and you can
click here to learn about what's going
on with guardians of the galaxy - thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you